Craig it is so wonderful to connect with
you at a time like this
where music has been redefined in
isolation everyone is going through
these emotions that we've never
experienced before
so what is it like for you to be able to
release an album at a time like this I
mean I gotta be honest as far as the
process in and of itself it's not a lot
different what makes it different is
this right here well you and I are
talking this way instead of me coming
and seeing you or we're sitting in a
studio or anything like that so yeah
that's a lot different but but I got to
be honest I think the response is is
greater because people aren't able to go
to the shows they aren't able to go
necessarily and buy the CDs so they're
looking for other ways to do that and
with the opportunity of debt with
downloads and all the social media
platforms that were utilizing to do some
things I think it's actually enhanced it
to some degree yeah Craig and these
songs it takes you on an emotional
roller coaster five new songs you put
other songs on this album that we're
from your previous album why bring these
particular songs together a couple of
reasons one of the reasons I put some of
the previous material on as you may know
I've been doing this for almost 20 years
a lot of people that have come into our
genre in fact I would say in the last
few years but I would even go as far as
to say in the last month or so there are
so many more people listening to our
music now than were a month ago because
of the situation so I put some of the
hits on there so that they would know
even though you may not have listened to
country music you have ran across that's
what I love about Sunday so that they
would hear that know it I also put some
of the older material that never was a
single on country radio because I
thought they were great songs that
should have been at some point yeah of
course the new material because I think
it's important that that we always are
introducing the fans to some of the new
music so the fans that have been them
has been with us for some time they now
have at least five new songs that they
get to listen to
you know I find it fascinating that
album title God family country which was
a song from your second album I loved it
why use that song title for this album
well the material in this album that
title really encompasses for one the
three things that are most important to
me and I feel like every song on this
record old and new all encompass one of
those three subject matters and that's
what I love about Sunday that could
easily fall under God and family and
quite honestly country depending on
whether you're looking at it from the
country the term being utilized as our
country or country music and then the
father my son Holy Ghost that to family
God soldier that is all about you know
country and supporting our military
those kind of things mm-hmm talking
about that song I've been listening to
it over and over and as a mother it is
difficult to listen to but it's an
anthem for so many people who have lost
a loved one I guess it doesn't get
easier to sing that song I'm sure
because it's such an emotional moment
for you what does it mean that you you
are able to put a song out there for
people who can actually reflect through
that song and get through those emotions
you hit the nail on the head that song
is very difficult every night I tell
people and I'm not exaggerating in the
least when I perform that song by the
time I'm finished with it and if there's
a reason I do it towards the end of my
show I literally feel like I've run a
marathon it just takes so much energy
for me to refrain or hold my emotions
back and in order to sing it that by the
time I'm done with it I just feel worn
out I feel beat up but it's also I also
do it because I do know that even though
it might hurt me to do it I do
appreciate the positive impact that that
song is having on people's lives and I
know that because of all the messages
that I get on Facebook and Instagram and
the tweets and and the website the email
is and so on and so forth so I see and
understand and appreciate the importance
of the
music and how impacting that song can be
on people's lives I have to tell you I
lost it when you see Karen's name and
the song your wife's name
are is she able to hear it or your kids
able to hear this song or they avoid it
I think there's a little bit of both I
think it kind of depends on their their
daily frame of mind you know some days
are harder than others some days we're
able to to smile more than other days
but there are days when we wake up and
and and it's just hard you know you wake
up crying thinking about it but you you
you you pray and you realize that like I
tell them and I tell other people I
can't say anything that's gonna make you
feel better but what I can tell you is
focus on all of the blessings that we
had during their presence rather than
think about the things that were not
getting in their absence yeah thank you
for the song it is absolutely beautiful
and so many people think that song is
beautiful including some guy named Blake
Shelton listen to this song you were on
Kelly Clarkson show and she surprised
you with Blake Shelton I know he's lost
someone in his family as well what was
the conversation after the show being
able to reconnect and with everything
that's happened well we had been talking
on the phone I was just really shocked
they did surprise me with him coming in
to visit it's the same conversation we
always had believe it or not we do more
we talk more about the music when we're
talking about the music with other
people when he and I are hanging out
about the music a lot believe it or not
we're talking about our farms we talk
about our families you know with he and
Gwen and the kids there was a lot of
questions about that because it's really
funny to see Blake in that role so I got
to pick on him in that great I'm sure
he's doing great a self-isolation
teaching kids how to educate right late
he must be doing great job yeah it's
just I'm just glad they're known not old
enough to drink now Blake is he's a
right dad he's not yeah yeah yeah our
beautiful people and we just love him to
death so will there be a collaboration
between you two never I don't like his
singing that will I did I'm kidding I
don't know you know for the first time
in our 15 or 18 20 year friendship for
the first time we just recently talked
about maybe doing something like I said
Blake and I are buddies and we have been
for many years and our friendship is
based on everything except our music
ironically enough I love Blake I think
he's one of the most talented singers
out there the guys really sharp he's
great at picking songs and and and he's
and he's a pretty decent writer he's a
fair writer but but but our like I said
our friendship is not about that our
friendships about our families and our
our lives outside of that